My name is Andrea Sozzi Sabatini,
and I'm the CEO and founder of Etrurio.
It's a farm where it aims to produce
top-quality olive oil in Tuscany.
Today, I'm going to walk you through
how Marco restores this beautiful
583-year-old fresco.
The first work that we have to do
is to consolidate the walls.
The first thing is
really to take the stones
that are unstable, take them off,
consolidate whatever is underneath,
and then put the stones
back to their places.
In this large fresco, there
are cracks here and there,
so the next step is to
consolidate these cracks.
The cracks get consolidated
with resin, special resin.
The next step is now
to remove the plasters
that had been painted over the fresco
in the last few centuries.
And to do that, Marco, the restorer,
needs to get archeological scalpel
and remove every single bit and pieces
out of this huge surface.
And it's very delicate work,
because if you are not precise enough
of course you can damage
the fresco itself.
Now that the plaster has been removed,
we can apply Japanese paper
soaked with water and ammonium carbonate.
This is a very delicate process.
And the reason why we
are doing it is because,
thanks to the Japanese paper,
all the dirt and all
the external component
get away from the fresco.
And it's a process that
can last up to six months.
After all this work, as you can see,
the fresco is revealing itself.
Some of the colors are now vivid.
What was underneath the plaster
fortunately is still there for most of it.
We are actually applying
again Japanese paper
soaked with a different
product, carbonate hydroxide.
And this is a very important
part of the fresco restoration,
because it stabilize the fresco itself.
Now that all these
processes are completed,
Marco can start the second
phase of the restoration.
As you can see,
there's a lot of gaps in the fresco,
because some of the paint has faded,
some others were lost.
He's going to use a
very tiny, small brush,
and he is going to use a natural pigment,
like they were used back in the 1400s.
There has been a surveillance
of the Italian authority over this fresco.
We are not allowed in Italy
to paint back anything
that is not present.
The whole restoration took a long time.
It took 18 months.
We are very proud that
we didn't lose this
piece of art in Tuscany.